This brings us to the definition
of constraint propagation.
Constraint propagation
is a method of inference
that assigns values to variables
characterizing a problem in such a way
that some conditions are satisfied.
So if you have any problem,
that problem is going to be
characterized by some variables.
And the task is to give specific values
to each variable in such a way that
some global constraints
have been satisfied.
So given a problem, some problems
are characterized by a set of variables,
each variable may locally
take on some values.
So probably the question is, how can
we locally assign values to variables
in such a way that some global
constraints are satisfied?
As an example,
let us return to this figure.
Here is a figure, drawn on a 2D surface,
and the problem is whether or
not it represents a 3D object.
The variables here are the surfaces and
the orientations.
One could consider this to be a single,
two dimensional surface with
some lines drawn on it.
Alternatively, one can think of
this as having four surfaces,
one, two, three, four, where each
surface has a particular orientation.
The orientation can be specified by
the perpendicular of that surface.
The method of constraint propagation is
going to help identify the surfaces and
their orientations.
The constraints here
are defined by these junctions.
For trihedral objects where three
surfaces meet at a particular point,
these junctions have certain properties.
No matter how we assign
these surfaces and
their orientations, the assignment
must satisfy all of those constraints.
We'll look at the details of
constraint propagation in a minute.
But first notice that there are two
possible interpretations to this
particular 3D object.
One can look at it as if one
were looking inside a box.
Alternatively, one can look at it as
if one were looking at a building.
This means that constraint
propagation need not
necessarily always succeed in
this ambiguity between different
kind of assignments of
surfaces in the orientation.
Sometimes multiple interpretations
can simultaneously satisfy
all the constraints.
It is also possible that no assignment
of values with variables will satisfy
all the constraints, in which case
interpretation becomes very difficult.
As another example,
let us examine this sentence.
Colorless green ideas sleep furiously.
All of us can recognize that this
is semantically meaningless, but
grammatically correct.
How did we know that this
is grammatically correct?
The variables here are the various
lexical categories, like words and
nouns and some different predicates.
The values are the assignments we
make to these various words here.
Is green a noun?
Is green a verb?
Green a determiner?
Is it part of a subject or
part of a predicate?
The constraints here are defined with
the rules of English language grammar.
As we assign values to the various
variables here, that assignment
must satisfy the constraints of
the English language grammar so
that as we assign values
to these variables,
those assignments must satisfy
the constraints of the English language
grammar before we can accept this
sentence to be grammatically correct.
If this sentence was
grammatically not correct,
then we will not be able to assign
values to all the variables in a way
that will satisfy the constraints
imposed by the English language grammar.
>> So we've actually come across this
idea of constraints in English language
grammar before.
During our lesson on understanding we
talked about how a preposition, for
example, can constrain the meaning
of the word that follows it.
If we see the word from, for example,
we expect what comes after it to be
some kind of source for the sentence.
There we used grammatical constraints
in service of some kind of
semantic analysis.
Here we're just using grammatical
constraints to figure out if a sentence
is grammatically correct or not.
There's another connection
here to understanding as well.
Ashok talked about how we can
interpret this shape as either popping
out towards us or down into the screen.
We talked about two simultaneously
accurate interpretations of the same
thing and understanding with regard to
sentences that can be read as puns.
So for example, when I said,
it's hard to explain puns to
kleptomaniacs because they
always take things literally.
The word take can simultaneously
be interpreted as interpret and
physically remove, while satisfying
all the constraints of the sentence.